merci d'être avec nous Laurence Cohen
vous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénatrice
communiste du Val-de-Marne
Vice-Présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales on va bien sûr
longuement parler du budget de la
Sécurité sociale qui commence cet
après-midi et de la question de
l'hôpital mais d'abord un mot sur le
pouvoir d'achat puisque dans une
interview parisien il y a Bruno Le Maire
défend la proposition d'Emmanuel Macron
dans dividende salarié c'est-à-dire une
entreprise qui verse des dividendes à
ses actionnaires doivent merci à ces
salariés le dividende salarié c'est le
profit de tous dit-il il propose une
convention de la majorité sur le sujet
qui pourrait déboucher sur une
proposition de loi est-ce que vous
pourriez la soutenir écoutez je trouve
que on est on marche sur la tête
c'est-à-dire que ça fait des mois et des
mois que les salariés demandent des
augmentations de salaire il y a une
grève des transports jeudi et tout à
coup le gouvernement sort de son chapeau
des propositions qui vont à l'encontre
des demandes des syndicats mais
qu'est-ce qui est demandé c'est une
augmentation des salaires une
augmentation du Smic une augmentation de
tous les salaires et puis
en l'indexant sur sur l'invitation à
savoir donc ce qu'on appelle l'échelle
mobile des salaires et qu'est-ce que
répond le gouvernement totalement autre
chose donc là on voit bien qu'on est
dans un conflit entre capital et travail
ce qu'il faut faire c'est effectivement
que les entreprises puissent augmenter
les salaires et pour le faire puisque
elle n'en ont pas envie et bien il faut
qu'il y ait des sanctions qui leur
soient qui leur soit infligés or c'est
pas ce que fait le gouvernement le
gouvernement dit mais finalement on va
on va aider en réalité les entreprises
et on va soit disant permettre aux
salariés d'avoir une part de la valeur
etc mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on me demande pas aux
entreprises absolument clairement de
prendre un petit peu sur leurs
dividendes de prendre sur leur énorme
profit je pense au labo pharmaceutique
mais il y en a plein il y a total etc
mais on veut surtout pas égratigner ces
profils mais donc là le dividende
salarié c'est non pour vous bah ça ne
répond pas ça serait quand même savoir
d'achat pour les salariés et c'est du
pouvoir de Chassier c'est toujours
finalement une mesure qui va à
l'encontre des intérêts des Françaises
et des Français il faut l'augmentation
des salaires il faut que les entreprises
mettent la main à la poche et c'est
possible vu les profits qu'elles font et
je parle des grandes entreprises je
parle pas des petites vous a répondu
Bruno le Merlin dans cette interview
parisien augmentait automatiquement tous
les salaires sur l'inflation c'est
augmenter d'autant tous les prix sans
fin il n'y aura que des perdants mais
mais voilà c'est c'est de l'enfumage
c'est pas c'est pas ça parce que c'est
de l'enfumage parce que on peut bloquer
les prix notamment les prix de première
nécessité et on peut avec des sanctions
infligées aux entreprises qui ne suivent
pas les directives à savoir
l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation du SMIC on peut y arriver
par exemple je vais vous donner un autre
exemple comment on est en 2022 comment
se fait-il qu'on n'est pas obtenu
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes ça fait des milliards d'euros
pour l'économie ce sont des entreprises
qui sont contrevenantes il faut
absolument que finalement il y ait des
aides qui soient donnés aux entreprises
quand elles sont vertueuses on parle
quand même d'un gain si on arrivait à ça
de 100 à 200 milliards d'euros donc vous
voyez là il y a de l'argent
parler du budget de la Sécurité sociale
puisque vous débutez à 16h l'examen de
ce texte dans l'hémicycle du Sénat et
s'adopter par 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale on voit tout ça avec notre
journaliste parlementaire tout ça
[Musique]
et Alex on va voir avec vous d'abord
quels sont les grandes lignes de ce
budget de la Sécu porté par le
gouvernement alors ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que avec ce budget bien le trou de
la Sécu est en train de se résorber car
après et bien l'épidémie de covid 19 qui
avait creusé les déficits en 2020 les
filles de la sécurité sociale s'élever à
39 milliards d'euros en 2021 à 25
milliards d'euros et ça y est on est
vraiment sur la pente descendante avec
un déficit pour l'an prochain pour la
sécurité sociale qui s'élèverait à 6,8
milliards d'euros ensuite avec ce budget
le gouvernement souhaite augmenter les
moyens à des EHPAD 3000 infirmiers
aide-soignants viendront renforcer les
effectifs dans ces établissements
première étape d'un plan qui vise à
recruter 50
000 personnels supplémentaires judicia
2027 dans les EHPAD et puis ça
ajouteront également avec ce budget 4000
places supplémentaires dans les services
d'aide à domicile pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux ensuite et bien ce
texte allonge d'un an les études de
médecine en internat pour que les des
médecins internes réalise des stages en
dehors de l'hôpital et en priorité dans
les déserts médicaux
est accueilli ici au Sénat notamment par
la majorité de droite j'aime bien
l'accueil est glacial de la part de la
majorité de droite et du centre au Sénat
puisque les sénateurs refusent la
trajectoire budgétaire de la sécurité
sociale même si l'an prochain le déficit
diminue il devrait selon les sénateurs
augmenter dans les années à venir
ensuite la droite sénatoriale est aussi
sceptique sur les moyens qui sont donnés
à l'hôpital malgré l'enveloppe de 400
millions d'euros qui a été débloqué la
semaine dernière en urgence à la
dernière minute pour l'hôpital et les
urgences pédiatriques par le ministre de
la Santé François Brown et puis comme
chaque année la majorité de droits de
sénatoriales proposent sa propre réforme
des retraites vient via un amendement au
texte il donne d'abord un an au
partenaire sociaux pour se mettre
d'accord sur une solution pour
équilibrer le système des retraites et
en cas d'échec des négociations entre
les partenaires sociaux et bien il
prendrait les mesures suivantes d'abord
recul de l'âge légal de départ à la à 64
ans augmentation de la durée de
cotisation pour atteindre 43 annuités
dès le départ en retraite de la
génération 1967 et puis convergence des
différents régimes spéciaux d'ici à 2023
c'est une manière d'ouvrir le débat sur
la réforme des retraites avant le texte
du Gouvernement qui attendu cet hiver on
va écouter le spécialiste des retraites
au Sénat René Paul Savary nous sommes
fidèles à nos convictions qu'il faut
être comme les autres pays européens
avoir un délai de travail suffisant pour
prendre en compte cette espérance de vie
qui a augmenté de façon à ce qu'on
puisse maintenir le niveau des des
retraites parce que c'est une
préoccupation si on ne prend pas les
mesures et bien nous ferons des
retraités pauvres et il y aura une
baisse progressive de pouvoir d'achat
des retraités ce que je ne souhaite pas
bien sûr nos concitoyens voilà c'est
très forme des retraites de la droite
sénatoriale elle ressemble à celle qui
est souhaitée par Emmanuel Macron alors
qui a copié qui a c'est le gouvernement
qui est venu sur notre ligne estime
Gérard Larcher
comme d'ailleurs l'ensemble de mes
collègues mais je suis une sénatrice de
terrain je me déplace dans les hôpitaux
de mon département le Val-de-Marne et je
peux vous dire que la colère est très
grande et ce qui est en train de se
passer est grave parce que on voit les
personnels hospitaliers qui quittent
l'hôpital en étant complètement épuisé
exténué et en trouvant finalement il y a
une perte de leur de leur métier et ça
c'est grave parce que le gouvernement
n'y répond pas et n'écoute pas ni ce qui
se passe à l'hôpital ni ce que nous on
relaie au niveau de mon groupe le groupe
communiste au Sénat on va parler de
l'hôpital dans quelques instants avec la
presse régionale un plus spécifiquement
mais vous avez décidé de déposer une
notion de rejet sur ce texte pourquoi
parce que je suis très en colère je suis
très en colère comme l'ensemble de mon
groupe et nous relayons le
mécontentement et l'inquiétude qui règne
au niveau de l'hôpital mais aussi au
niveau de la médecine de ville écoutez
là j'entends que le budget de la
Sécurité sociale au niveau du déficit ça
va mieux etc mais il faut qu'on soit
clair c'est encore 80 maintenant
aujourd'hui 80 milliards d'exonérations
de cotisations sociales c'est-à-dire
plus 10 milliards d'exonérations de
cotisations sociales qui sont un manque
pour les caisses de sécurité sociale
alors le gouvernement et monsieur
dussobe nous dit mais vous inquiétez pas
l'état qu'on pense mais ça veut dire que
c'est de l'argent qui manquent pour
l'hôpital ça veut dire que c'est de
l'argent qui manque pour embaucher ça
veut dire que c'est de l'argent qui
manque pour réouvrir des lits donc on
arrête avec ça il y a besoin de ne pas
assécher les dépenses de ne pas assécher
pardon les recettes de la sécurité
sociale et donc il faut arrêter cette
politique d'exonération donc comme le
gouvernement ne veut rien entendre et
n'écoute pas nos propositions qui si
elles étaient entendues et bien
permettrait à l'hôpital de reprendre du
souffle et bien nous nous posons cette
question préalable en tout cas dans ce
budget de la Sécurité sociale il y a une
hausse des moyens des EHPAD vous
reconnaissez que ça ça va dans le bon
sens écoutez c'est toujours d'une
politique des petits pas vous avez
annoncé les chiffres vous savez ce que
demande les professionnels ils demandent
100000 créations de poste chaque année
pendant 3 ans c'est-à-dire 300000
créations de poste et là on est
complètement en dessous c'est de
l'enfumage le gouvernement ne veut rien
entendre et on est en train de casser
notre système de santé et notamment ce
qui est très grave tout ce qui est
service public alors il y a aussi la
question des déserts médicaux n'en parle
beaucoup en ce moment avec cette
proposition du gouvernement qui est
d'ailleurs un petit peu la même du côté
de la droite sanatoriale d'allonger les
études de médecine en internat et cette
année supplémentaire et bien elle serait
faite en priorité dans les déserts
médicaux vous pensez que ça va améliorer
l'offre de soins dans les territoires
sous dotés mais non absolument pas là
encore ça a été fait en dépit du bon
sens c'est-à-dire il y a eu aucune
concertation avec les syndicats des
internes ça s'est fait sans anticipation
sans réflexion sur la formation et on
s'est pertinemment que les jeunes
professionnels qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
aujourd'hui ils veulent travailler
collectivement en salariat et on leur
dit vous allez aller faire des stages en
libéral avec avec des seniors or on
manque il y a on manque de de médecins
traitant il y a 6 millions de patients
qui n'ont pas de médecin traitant
comment ils vont être encadrés nous la
solution que nous proposons une des
solutions c'est que le gouvernement
donne des moyens au centre de santé
aujourd'hui il peut y avoir des centres
de santé dans chaque département qui
soit supplémentaires qui soient donc
aider par ce gouvernement or qu'est-ce
que fait le gouvernement là encore il
crée des discriminations pour les
maisons de santé par exemple il y a
150000 euros qui sont débloqués d'aide
pour trois professionnels et pour les
centres de santé 75000 donc c'est à dire
la moitié moins on voit bien que ça ne
va pas c'est à dire que le gouvernement
comme la droite sénatoriale d'ailleurs
ne connaissent pas quelles sont les
aspirations aujourd'hui des jeux de
médecins donc ils prennent les choses à
l'envers on va également oui un mot sur
ces déserts médicaux puisque le une
partie de la majorité horizon notamment
voulait des mesures plus coercitives sur
ces désert médicaux pour que les
médecins aillent dans les déserts
médicaux ça a été rejeté par le
gouvernement est-ce que pour vous il
faut des mesures coercitives mais il
faut déjà on constate il y a la Cour des
comptes qu'il dit c'est pas le groupe
communiste déjà les les mesures
incitatives ne vont pas donc je parle
moi de des centres de santé et nous nous
pensons qu'il faut un conventionnement
sélectif c'est-à-dire là où
effectivement il y a beaucoup de
médecins et bien il faut arrêter de
conventionner la droite du Sénat la
majorité de droits de sénatoriales veut
ouvrir le débat sur la réforme des
retraites dans ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
votre collègue René Paul Savary
sénateurs de la républicain qui dit que
si on équilibre pas notre système de
retraite et bien dans l'avenir on aura
des retraités pauvres là encore je
trouve que évidemment c'est une logique
c'est une logique
ultralibérale on est en 2022 on a une
espérance de vie qui est effectivement
plus importante et on nous dit il faut
travailler plus longtemps et on voit que
les gens il y a un certain nombre de
personnes notamment dans des métiers
avec une grande pénibilité qui sont
absolument cassées et on leur dit il
faut continuer alors que si vous
regardez le taux de chômage chez les
jeunes et chez les personnes justement
âgées il y a un taux qui est important
donc il faut arrêter en est en 2022 on
devrait pouvoir travailler moins
longtemps 32 heures ça serait ça serait
possible au lieu d'aller à 40 heures et
on devrait pouvoir s'arrêter bien plus
tôt au lieu de pressurer les salariés
comme ils le sont aujourd'hui et du coup
comment on financerait notre système de
retraite mais là aussi le le système des
retraites c'est exactement la même chose
si on veut que notre système de
protection sociale tiennent debout il
faut arrêter d'assécher les recettes et
j'en ai fait
les cotisations retraite et ben surtout
on arrêterait d'exonérer on financerait
notre système de protection de
protection sociale c'est ça qui est
extrêmement important aujourd'hui si
vous voulez on assèche les dépenses au
détriment de l'hôpital au détriment de
l'assurance maladie au détriment des des
retraités et et après et bien finalement
on est en train de pleurer en disant ah
quelle solution on va pouvoir
prendre et qui sont mauvaises pour
l'ensemble des salariés des retraités
est-ce que vous avez voté elle est
surtaxes qui sont proposées par la
majorité de droits de sénatoriales et
qui concerne les mutuelles et les
laboratoires d'analyses médicales bah
écoutez moi je vais vous savez au au
niveau de notre groupe on va examiner
comment le débat se déroule déjà je ne
sais pas ce que ce qui va en être pose
déjà une question préalable où on dit
que c'est pas possible on est en colère
ce but monsieur ce budget ne va pas ne
correspond pas à la réalité il est même
un sincère donc déjà on n'est pas pour
le budget tel qu'il nous est présenté et
on va avoir après si notre motion est
rejetée comment et bien on va on va
voter suivant les mesures qui vont qui
vont être prises par exemple moi
j'aurais souhaité que on taxe davantage
les grands laboratoires pharmaceutiques
qui se sont fait des milliards d'euros
de profit pendant la pandémie je pense
notamment à Sanofi malgré son échec pour
la découverte du vaccin du covid merci
Alex on suivra bien sûr ce qui se passe
dans l'hémicycle à partir de 16h et
demain compte rendu de cette séance avec
vous on va parler de puces plus
spécifiquement pardon de la question de
l'hôpital on va à Marseille on retrouve
Léo purgat président et directeur
éditorial du Journal La Marseillaise
pour Léo merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et vous revenez sur la visite vendredi à
Marseille du ministre de la Santé
François Brune
oui tout à fait le ministre de la Santé
est venu à Marseille vendredi jeudi il
était également à Avignon pour présenter
notamment le suivi numérique des
patients il a été à chaque fois
confronté aux mécontentement du
personnel qui estime que le Ségur n'est
pas à la hauteur et que il y a besoin
absolument
de moyens supplémentaires pour leur
permettre de d'assurer leur mission donc
ça m'amène à la question que j'avais
envie de poser à Laurence Cohen on sait
qu'avec votre groupe vous avez fait un
tour des hôpitaux avant même la crise
sanitaire où vous aviez alerté sur la
situation de l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui il suffit pas d'avoir raison
sur le constat Vous ministre de la Santé
et bien quel serait vos premières
mesures pour faire cesser cette spirale
délétère pour l'hôpital public
et bien écoutez c'est vrai que il suffit
pas d'avoir raison en amont il faut
avoir des des propositions je les dis
déjà il faut faire rentrer de l'argent
dans les caisses de la Sécurité sociale
arrêtez les exonérations de cotisations
patronales parce que ça fait un manque à
gagner extrêmement important justement
pour l'hôpital il faut arrêter avec ces
tondames là je veux quand même donner
quelques chiffres on est après la crise
on aurait pu penser que le gouvernement
aurait tiré un certain nombre
d'enseignements à la crise covid or long
dame augmente c'est-à-dire chez
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie effectivement le
plafond a pas dépassé voilà le plafond a
pas dépassé il augmente de 3,7% or 3,7%
d'où le mécontentement des Hospitaliers
c'est en dessous des dépenses de santé
qui sont prévisibles et c'est aussi en
dessous pour la première fois de
l'inflation donc on voit là le manque à
gagner c'est à dire qu'avec ce budget le
gouvernement fait économie de près de 2
milliards 1,7 milliards exactement sur
le système de santé donc il faut déjà
hausser les les recettes au niveau de
notre système de protection sociale il
faut revaloriser les salaires il faut
faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus les
exclus du Ségur il faut améliorer les
conditions de travail pour améliorer les
conditions de travail il faut donc
ré-ouvrir des lits et donc il faut que
la profession au niveau des
professionnels de santé ou du
médico-social soit à nouveau attractive
donc il faut qu'il y ait des cadences
qui sont qui soient moins importantes
donc il faut ré-embaucher alors le
gouvernement vous direz qu'il a fait
tout ça qui a une Ségure qui a eu 10
milliards qu'il a débloqué le numerus
clausus et que du coup une fois que
c'est médecin seront opérationnels les
lits pourront ouvrir François Brunel a
débloqué 400 millions d'euros pour les
services en tension pour vous c'est pas
il y a pas de réponse mais les réponses
sont insuffisantes si vous voulez quand
il fait ils font le Ségur et bien
qu'est-ce ils font ils excluent des
personnels sacrés une un mécontentement
terrible on le leur dit mais une
rectifie pas le tir quand on parle de
milliards d'euros on parle pas là je
vous ai dit une économie à nouveau si ça
fait 30 ans qu'il y a des économies sur
le dos de l'hôpital et du système de
santé donc il est à l'os là pour parler
donc
Emmanuel Macron c'est ses paquets que ce
gouvernement ça dépend de quel goût je
vous parlais effectivement Sarkozy
Hollande et et Macron voilà mais nous au
niveau des communistes on n'a pas
participé à ce à cette à cette politique
là nous on est toujours pour une
politique de santé qui partent des
besoins des des patients et des patients
et c'est pas ce que fait le gouvernement
et quand il y a le feu tout à coup il
arrive mais il arrive avec une petite
cuillère remplie d'eau alors qu'il
faudrait effectivement un camion de
pompiers ouais et sur le les 400
millions la débloquer récemment pour les
services en tension alors c'était 150
millions François on a monté à monter
l'enveloppe à 400 millions pour vous
c'est à la hauteur de l'enjeu mais non
c'est pas la hauteur de l'enjeu et c'est
pas là encore c'est pas moi qui lui dis
c'est pas mon groupe c'est l'ensemble
des professionnels écouter les les les
les la colère les revendications des
personnels au niveau au niveau de la
pédiatrie enfin quand j'ai dit dans
l'hémicycle fin octobre lors de ma
question au gouvernement la question que
je posais au niveau de mon groupe qu'il
y avait un tri des patients etc affreux
de choisir entre deux enfants il y a eu
des hués sur le banc du du gouvernement
mais là encore c'est les clés c'est les
témoignages que je reçois c'est des
enfants qui sont qui ne peuvent pas être
soignés de bonnes façons au niveau de
l'Île-de-France et qui sont envoyés
ailleurs vous vous rendez compte pour
des enfants et pour des familles comment
ça se passait ça la réalité aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui de l'hôpital mais on
continue le gouvernement on continue à
fermer des il se sert en fait de la
politique d'austérité qu'il a mené qu'il
continue à amener pour réduire l'hôpital
public au profit de du privé un dernier
mot là-dessus parce qu'il y a un sondage
hier dans le Journal du dimanche il faut
qu'il dit que 73 % une image négative de
l'hôpital vous dites il faut augmenter
les salaires il y a des postes à
pourvoir qui ne sont pas pour vous
est-ce que pour vous la solution c'est
l'augmentation des salaires est-ce que
ça va suffire non
s'il y avait qu'une solution ça serait
extrêmement facile c'est vrai que compte
tenu de la situation que j'ai décrite il
y a une foultitude de de
solutions qui sont à proposer il y a
l'augmentation des salaires il y a les
les embauches il y a donc aussi une
restructuration opérée moi là encore les
témoignages des Hospitaliers c'est de
dire qu'il faut absolument redonner vie
redonner sens au service parce que on a
on a privilégié justement tout ce qui
était
l'hôpital a été considéré comme une
entreprise la tarification à l'acte il
doit absolument elle doit absolument
être supprimée or elle perdure tout à
l'heure je ne sais plus si c'est vous
votre collègue vous avez dit mais le
numerus clausus ça y est il a été ouvert
mais là encore ils se sont repassés la
patate chaude perdre permettez-moi cette
expression parce que effectivement les
unis on a dit aux universités il faut
former plus de médecins sauf qu'on aura
pas donné les moyens donc c'est au
compte-goutte il y a très très peu de
professionnels qui sont supprimés je
suis orthophoniste paramédical il y a un
manque cruel d'orthophoniste dans tout
le territoire que ce soit dans
l'Hexagone ou au niveau ultramarin or on
ne desserre pas les taux on ne forme pas
plus de professionnels c'est ça qui ne
va pas il faut supprimer aussi cette
histoire de numérus clausus parce que on
a vu aussi au niveau des études
d'infirmières il y a des des hommes et
des femmes qui rentrent mais qui
n'avaient pas choisi ce métier là comme
premier choix et du coup qui s'en vont
au bout d'un an au bout de deux ans qui
ne sont pas au bout donc il faut arrêter
cette sélection qui est stupide
on va retourner à Marseille on va parler
de la Une de La Marseillaise cette
fois-ci Léo un tout autre sujet elle a
une de la Marseillaise vous parlez de la
colle des migrants
oui tout à fait avec Mimo Lucano qui est
l'ex-maire de Riache qui est une petite
communauté calabraise qui avait ouvert
largement ses portes aux migrants
son maire a été condamné en première
instance en Italie à 13 ans de prison il
était accueilli ce week-end par Benoît
Payen le maire de Marseille qui lui a
remis une médaille de la ville en
attendant le verdict de son procès en
appel et pendant ce temps effectivement
il y a toujours un avis de SOS
Méditerranée avec 240 migrants à son
bord qui attend de trouver un port sûr
pour débarquer la question que je
voulais poser à la sénatrice Cohen et
bien c'est comment comment gérer cette
question migratoire avec comme voisin
une Italie gouvernée par l'extrême
droite
alors déjà moi quand j'entends qu'il y a
des migrants qui sont sur un bateau
qu'ils attendent finalement de pouvoir
être accueilli j'ai honte j'ai honte
pour la France j'ai honte pour ce pays
des droits de l'homme où on sait les
conditions de passage de ces femmes et
de ses hommes des violences qui ne
subissent or si les gens viennent
quittent leur pays c'est pas par plaisir
c'est parce qu'ils sont chassés par la
guerre par la pauvreté économique mais
aussi par les problèmes climatiques et
quand ils viennent ils sont super
exploités ici c'est ça la réalité moi je
soutiens en ce moment les les
travailleurs de chez Chronopost ils sont
exploités ils sont sans papiers on les
fait travailler dans des conditions de
travail qui sont proches de l'esclavage
Chronopost avec service public
extrêmement important à l'intérieur et y
compris au niveau enfin fonds publics
avec une partie importante du
gouvernement et j'ai fait travailler
extrêmement dur on ne reconnaît pas
leur travail si il protestent ils
doivent prendre la porte alors que ils
sont utilisés comme une main d'oeuvre
quand mais corvéable à Bercy donc il y a
une il y a une hypocrisie on fait venir
ces migrants pour qu'ils travaillent sur
des sur des un travail qui n'est pas
pris aux Français comme je l'entends
dire et aux françaises mais bien au
contraire et finalement on ne le
reconnaît pas leur citoyenneté alors
justement Gérald Darmanin il dit moi je
vais mettre fin à cette hypocrisie je
propose un statut avec Olivier dussope
un statut de travailleur pour les
métiers en tension avec un titre de
séjour pour ces étrangers qui
travaillent dans ces métiers en tension
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée chiche
moi je voudrais bien connaître
exactement quelle est la mesure jusqu'au
bout parce que ce que j'ai entendu
jusqu'à présent c'est effectivement ce
que vous dites mais en même temps on
considère l'individu tout seul
c'est-à-dire sans lien familiaux sans
rien il vient il bosse et c'est
uniquement par rapport au travail et si
jamais il y a un problème si jamais il
est renvoyé si jamais l'entreprise ne
veut plus de lui parce que finalement et
bien il n'en a plus besoin qu'est-ce qui
se passe donc si vous voulez on n'est
pas là sur le règlement d'un problème
d'un point de vue objectif d'un point de
vue à la fois humain d'un point de vue
économique il faut savoir que les
travailleurs qui viennent ici rapportent
à l'économie parce que là c'est un titre
de séjour d'un an sur des métiers en
tension si jamais le métier n'est plus
en tension l'année d'après c'est la fin
du titre de séjour vous vous dites il
faut de la régularisation et pas
seulement le titre de séjour dans ma vie
bien sûr il faut de la régularisation
c'est ça nous que nous demandons au
niveau au niveau de notre groupe et
c'est surtout pas cette épée de Damoclès
va vous vous rendez compte si ça dépend
uniquement du travail et donc de
l'entreprise ça veut dire que c'est je
le répète une main d'oeuvre cornée
corvéable à merci on a l'impression de
retourner autant de l'esclavage merci
Laurence Cohen merci
marseillaise Marseille
l'internationaliste c'est à la Une de
votre journal et au purgate merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous et merci
Laurence Cohen et dans 20 minutes dans
le club des territoires on va revenir
sur la question de la dissolution sur le
rassemblement national on en parle tout
de suite avec notre prochaine invitation
[Musique]